[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos en visual politic nos
hemos dado cuenta de un fallo bastante
grave llevamos más de 7 años lanzando
vídeos todos los meses sobre los lugares
y los temas Más variopintos sin embargo
en todo este tiempo nos hemos olvidado
del vecino ibérico de España de Portugal
Pero sabéis qué eso se acaba hoy con
conocido por sus famosos Navegantes y
exploradores como Vasco de Gama o
Fernando de Magallanes Portugal llegó a
ser hace siglos el mayor imperio de todo
Europa lo fue hasta que la corona de
Castilla alcanzó a América hoy sin
embargo se encuentra entre los países
más rezagados de Europa occidental de
hecho Esta es una circunstancia que
comparte con sus hermanos mediterráneos
con España y con Grecia y desde luego
tampoco es algo precisamente nuevo la
historia de Portugal está plagada de
inestabilidad y muchas muchísimas crisis
sin ir más lejos hace poco acabamos de
conocer la dimisión de su Primer
Ministro que está siendo investigado por
corrupción fijaos la dignidad de las
tareas de un Primer Ministro no son
compatibles con ninguna sospecha sobre
la integridad el buen comportamiento y
menos aún con cualquier tipo de acto
delictivo y de hecho como veréis en las
últimas décadas las dimisiones en este
país se han convertido Casi casi en un
deporte
nacional Claro que no todo es malo
sabéis que nos enseña también su
historia sobre todo la más reciente Pues
que con trabajo duro se puede salir de
prácticamente cualquier atolladero de
hecho Portugal se ha convertido para
muchos en un claro modelo a seguir para
hacer frente a nuevas crisis podríamos
incluso decir que la terrible crisis
financiera del 2008 que agitó todo el
mundo puso por fin las pilas a una
largada Portugal Claro que en el último
año también hemos podido ver noticias
como esta miles de personas se
manifiestan contra la carestía de la
vida amigos amigas justo cuando parecía
que Portugal estaba empezando a superar
todos sus grandes problemas este 2023 ha
supuesto otro jarro de agua fría sobre
este pequeño país europeo y precisamente
por eso en viso al polític nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas Cómo se
convirtió Portugal en una promesa
económica Cuál fue el precio que tuvo
que pagar por ello Por qué las protestas
están otra vez tomando las calles del
país luso pues bien hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes tenemos que empezar por el
principio de la historia arranquemos
[Música]
hacia el
Abismo muchos y no todos absolutamente
todos ya sabéis que cuando terminó la
Segunda Guerra Mundial el fascismo no
desapareció de Europa no al menos del
todo y sí lo imagino la gran mayoría
estaréis pensando Seguro seguro en
Francisco Franco El dictador español que
estuvo 36 años en el poder sin embargo
sabéis que pese a esos casi 40 años esta
no fue la dictadura más larga de Europa
occidental para encontrarla tenemos que
prestar atención precisamente a nuestro
protagonista de hoy a
Portugal La dictadura portuguesa que dio
comienzo en 1926 se convirtió en la más
longeva de de toda Europa occidental su
principal figura Antonio de oliveira
Salazar un economista que comenzó siendo
ministro de finanzas del dictador Óscar
de fragoso Carmona se convirtió en el
Primer Ministro de la dictadura en
1932 su Proyecto Del estado novo o
estado nuevo priorizó el orden por
encima de la economía lo que supuso
mucha censura y también la encarcelación
de muchísimos activistas y opositores
políticos pese a ello al menos consiguió
mantener a flote la economía del país lo
hizo eso sí a asumiendo tasas de
desarrollo mucho peores que las del
resto de
Europa en cualquier caso tras quedar
incapacitado después de sufrir una
embolia En
1968 La dictadura conocería sus últimos
años con el sucesor de Salazar con
Marcelo caetano al que le tocó lidiar
con los movimientos nacionalistas en las
colonias portuguesas de África y también
con la crisis de
[Música]
1973 el resultado es que al final tras
48 años La dictadura cayó tras el
alzamiento de los oficiales del propio
ejército en abril de
1974 un movimiento que pasó a la
historia con el nombre de la revolución
de los claveles a partir de ese momento
Portugal se sumergió en un turbio camino
repleto de cortas presidencias hasta
1986 cuando junto a España ingresó en la
comunidad económica Europea y se fue un
punto de inflexión fundamental Durante
los siguientes 20 años la economía lusa
creció un ritmo de prácticamente un 3%
anual no era para tirar cohetes pero
supuso un cambio de 180 gr Portugal
experimentó al igual que países como
España una enorme espiral de riqueza y
de modernización sin embargo en 2008 se
desató la tragedia ya es oficial
recesión desde diciembre de 2007 la
eurozona entra en recesión por primera
vez en la historia en nuestro canal
hermano en visual economic ya os hemos
hablado del origen de esta crisis de
como las hipotecas ninjas La burbuja
inmobiliaria provocada por la expansión
monetaria y el estallido de esta barrió
el sistema financiero internacional y se
llevó por delante a bancos como lean
brother pero en lo que respecta a
nuestro protagonista la cosa fue aún
peor en 2008 la economía portuguesa no
solo vio có estallaba su particular
burbuja inmobiliaria y Su economía
empezaba a caer sino que pocos años
después se desataría también una enorme
crisis de la deuda Pública del Estado Ya
de por sí bastante más endeudado que la
media de la Unión Europea con la crisis
Portugal tuvo que asumir de repente
enormes cantidades de
deuda en 2012 apenas 4 años después de
estallar la crisis la deuda pública ya
superaba el 120 del pib como veis el
problema Fue bastante similar al que se
produjo en la mayor parte de los países
del sur de Europa la crisis fue mucho
mayor de lo que nadie esperaba y el
gobierno portugués respondió intentando
alimentar la demanda con más y más gasto
público fue una especie de receta
hipercalórica donde en vez de calorías
pues sumas deudas intereses y luego más
deudas sin embargo El caso es que esta
dieta fue completamente inútil al final
al Primer Ministro José Sócrates no le
quedó más remedio que meter la tijera
simple llanamente porque las arcas
públicas se quedaron completamente
vacías en cierta forma el país se estaba
deshaciendo y amigos en esas estaban
cuando llegó al poder la figura clave de
la recuperación portuguesa estamos
hablando de Pedro pasos
coel pasos cuello el entonces líder del
conservador psd ganó las elecciones
anticipadas de 2011 con un amplio margen
el pueblo luso lo escogió para llevar a
cabo una misión recuperar Portugal para
hacerlo el nuevo gobierno tuvo que tomar
una difícil decisión la misma que
también se vieron obligados a tomar
Grecia e Irlanda aceptar el rescate de
la Europea y el fondo monetario
internacional en concreto Portugal
recibió 78,000 millones de euros eso sí
lo hizo con una condición abrazar la
austeridad económica cuello comenzó
entonces en los momentos más oscuros de
la crisis entre 2012 y 2013 a tomar las
decisiones más duras por ejemplo recortó
el gasto público en educación sanidad y
asuntos económicos un 7% redujo
drásticamente la protección al despido
en un momento en que el desempleo batí
todos sus récords con niveles de más del
15% por y congeló tanto el salario
mínimo en 500 como el salario de los
[Música]
funcionarios La pregunta es Fue un
proceso tranquilo pues no para nada como
os podéis imaginar ante semejante
panorama ocurrió lo que siempre solo
ocurrir En estos casos las protestas
comenzaron a inundar las calles pero
pese a todo en 2014 Después de tres
largos años de un enorme sufrimiento
económico el país comenzó a ver la luz
de una vez por todas no era en cualquier
caso un Punto de partida nada fácil
Portugal sale del rescate más
empobrecida y todavía lejos de la
recuperación Pero sabéis qué a partir de
entonces a Portugal No solo le preocupó
recuperarse por completo también quiso
blindarse ante futuras crisis un momento
blindarse ante futuras crisis de qué
estamos hablando exactamente Pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
sacando
músculo después de tocar fondo la
economía portuguesa comenzó a crecer de
nuevo lo hizo eso sí a un ritmo más
pausado del 2,3 por de media entre 2014
y 2019 pero aún así el desempleo logró
descender hasta poco más del 6% de esta
forma Aunque pasos coelo no logró
revalidar su mandato su gobierno logró
encauzar la situación económica y en
cierto modo preparar los cimientos de la
recuperación de la que luego por cierto
sacó pecho el exprimer ministro
socialista Antonio Costa Pero bueno ya
sabéis nada nuevo bajo el sol El caso es
que el gobierno de coelo no solo redujo
el gasto social sino que también sacó
adelante planes como el programa simplex
para reducir la burocracia de la
Administración pública esta medida por
ejemplo fue clave para recuperar la
inversión extranjera directa también se
logró empezar a reducir la deuda pública
que entre 2014 y 2019 cayó del 133 al
116 por del pib ojo aquí no estamos
hablando de ningún milagro como veis el
golpe de la crisis fue muy duro y los
datos de la poscrisis Pues tampoco son
para tirar cohetes Pero qué queréis que
os diga ver durante esa época Cómo se
reducía la deuda pública en uno de los
países con problemas del sur de Europa
era no sé como ver al psg ganar una
competición europea es algo que casi
nunca ocurre pero que Oye cuando lo hace
es que te dan ganas de llorar de emoción
Así que digamos que aquí el logro del
gobierno portugués es que consiguió
estabilizar las cosas Portugal devuelve
al fmi todos los créditos del rescate
financiero de 2011 el organismo
internacional le prestó más de 26,000
millones al 5,8 por de interés bueno
estabilizar las cosas y también mejorar
los propios cimientos económicos del
país y ojo que esto ha sido algo clave
por qué Pues porque en 2020 llegó la
pandemia y esta vez esta vez Portugal no
estuvo entre los rezagados sino en entre
los
aventajados en 2020 su economía cayó más
de un 8% pero en los dos años siguientes
creció en un 5 y un 6% respectivamente y
no solo eso el país logró que pese a
todos los esfuerzos la deuda pública se
redujera hasta el 113 en 2022 es decir
en 2022 el ratio de deuda pública de
Portugal era inferior al de 2019 Y eso
eso no ha sido nada pero que nada
común
amigos para muchos analistas Portugal se
ha convertido en algo así como una
especie de ejemplo al menos un ejemplo
realista asequible imitable un ejemplo
de un país que a base de incentivos
Fiscales mejoras regulatorias y una
captación activa de la inversión
extranjera ha conseguido resultados más
que satisfactorios hoy el desempleo es
relativamente bajo la economía crece y
sus parámetros Macro están mejorando
Claro que desgraciadamente Esta no es
toda la historia
atentos turismo e inversión igual a
crisis recordáis que os hemos dicho que
coelo redujo la burocracia para que
Portugal recibiera más inversión
extranjera Pues bien como os podéis
imaginar esta no fue la única medida que
tomó para conseguir encandilar a los
inversores Internacionales coelo se dio
cuenta de que podía conseguir un dos por
un si jugaba bien sus cartas no solo
tenía la oportunidad de ataer más
inversión sino también de luchar contra
uno de los mayores retos del país el
creciente envejecimiento demográfico sí
Portugal también es uno de esos países
que tienen por delante décadas muy pero
que muy complicadas amigos la población
mayor de 60 años supone ya casi el 30%
de la población portuguesa un porcentaje
que no dejará de crecer intensamente
Durante los próximos años Pues bien El
caso es que pasos coelo introdujo dos
polémicas medidas que pretendían atraer
inversión a la par que reducir la
presión demográfica cuo introdujo las
famosas visas oro y las visas startups
[Música]
fijaos introducidas en 2012 las visas
oro otorg la residencia extranjeros a
cambio de una inversión de 500,000 eur
en sus primeros 7 años lograron recaudar
más de 3400 millones de euros gracias a
la llegada de miles de inversores con
rentas estratosféricas desde china Rusia
Estados Unidos y varios Países Árabes
que querían disfrutar de una residencia
incluso de la posibilidad de conseguir
una nacionalidad europea al tiempo que
gozaban de las importantes
desgrabaciones Fiscales que este plan
les otorgaba por su lado la visa startup
fue impulsada usada para traer a
fundadores de compañías que pudieran
presentar proyectos con el potencial de
alcanzar un valor de
325,000 o un volumen de negocios anual
superior a los 500,000 en 3 años aunque
no otorgara la posibilidad de acceder a
la nacionalidad portuguesa Esta sí
contaba con los beneficios Fiscales que
también aplicaban a las visas oro razón
por la que la creación de startups en el
país se disparó hasta liderar la mejora
emprendedora en toda
Europa a ver que estas visas lograron
contribuir a disparar la inversión
extranjera es algo innegable sin embargo
no es oro todo lo que reluce estos
visados no solo llevaron dinero
extranjero a Portugal sino que también
contribuyeron a alimentar una nueva
crisis la crisis de la
vivienda y es que veréis al compás de la
recuperación económica la política
monetaria de tipos cero y también las
visas internacionales el precio de la
vivienda en Portugal se ha disparado por
ejemplo en Lisboa la capital el alquiler
medio de un piso ya ronda los 2,000 vale
esto por sí mismo Pues no nos dice nada
pero aquí viene lo problemático
recordáis que al principio del vídeo
veíamos como Portugal estaba casi el
último en renta per cápita en Europa
occidental Pues sí Portugal tiene un p
per cápita de alrededor de unos 24,000 y
un salario mínimo de unos 760 la cues es
creéis que con esas rentas pueden
permitirse un alquiler de 2000 en Lisboa
la verdad es que parece cuanto menos
difícil a menudo los beneficiarios de
programas libres de impuestos como las
visas doradas remodelan una casa pero no
la ocupan muchas veces esas propiedades
se venden una y otra vez y eso crea
distorsión en el mercado inmobiliario es
una de las causas de la crisis de la
vivienda Sí por supuesto la falta de
vivienda tiene más que ver con La
regulación del suelo y la construcción
que con las visas pero este modelo ha
contribuido a que su precio se dispare y
lo cierto Es que ni siquiera ha sido el
único ingrediente que ha contribuido a
empeorar la situación el turismo también
ha tenido mucho que ver en ciudades como
Porto por ejemplo las casas diseñadas
para visitantes temporales es decir los
pisos turísticos ya suponen cuatro de
cada 10 inmuebles en la ciudad y
lógicamente Entonces los locales los
portugueses están teniendo cada vez más
problemas para encontrar pisos
asequibles donde poder vivir y
evidentemente en países donde la oferta
es limitada si la demanda crece los
precios pues se disparan es de cajón y
eso es precisamente lo que explica
noticias como estas miles de personas
protestan en Portugal por crisis de la
vivienda Y qué ha ocurrido Pues que el
gobierno socialista de Antonio Costa
comenzó a tomar
medidas por ejemplo estableció un tope
del 2% a los aumentos de los precios
recogidos en los nuevos contratos de
alquiler incluso hizo que se aprobase la
obligación de alquilar las viviendas
privadas que estén vacías fijaos esto es
por ejemplo lo que decía sin ir más
lejos el proyecto de ley inicial
presentado por el partido socialista de
Portugal atento los propietarios de
viviendas tendrán un plazo de 100 días
desde la recepción de una propuesta de
alquiler de las autoridades municipales
Para volver a alquilar un inmueble vacío
en condiciones de habitabilidad conforme
a este proyecto los propietarios de
viviendas tendrían oj ojo la obligación
de comunicar a las autoridades locales
si un inmueble se queda vacío entonces
las corporaciones podrían hacer
propuestas de alquiler Y si el proceso
se extendiera durante más de 100 días y
la vivienda continuara vacía Entonces
los consistorios podrían alquilarla
forzosamente al precio que ellos mismos
hubieran establecido para luego
subarrendar selas a otras personas en
calidad de vivienda pública vale al
final esta medida quedó un poquito más
diluida en la ley aprobada finalmente
por el parlamento ahora esta medida se
aplica a los inmuebles que lleven más de
do años vacíos y que estén situados en
zonas cost pero aún así siento un Claro
precedente que ya os adelanto que a los
inversores no les va a gustar ni un pelo
y eso eso no es todo la nueva regulación
de vivienda también ha establecido duros
límites a los pisos turísticos
incluyendo un nuevo impuesto
extraordinario del 15% y como no también
se ha cargado el programa de Visas de
oro hablamos por tanto de uno de los
planteamientos políticos de vivienda más
radicales que se hayan visto en todao
Europa y eso es precisamente lo que
explica esta noticia presidente de la
república Beta programa más vivienda
Claro que en Portugal El veto
presidencial no es definitivo Así que la
ley volvió al parlamento y este la
aprobó y la reforma entró a vigor a
comienzos de octubre sin embargo lo
cierto Es que muchos portugueses son
escépticos de que este plan se llega a
consolidar Por qué pues por una simple
razón Portugal está sumido en una
profunda crisis
política amigos desde que el Primer
Ministro Costa lograra revalidar su
puesto en las elecciones de 2022 con
mayoría absoluta tuvo que lidiar con 12
renuncias de alos cargos de su gobierno
por diferentes escándalos lo que le
valió dos mociones de censura por parte
del bloque de la derecha por ejemplo
Carla Alves ya ex secretaria de estado
de agricultura dimitió tan solo un día
después de asumir su puesto cuando la
prensa dio a conocer el embargo de las
cuentas bancarias que tenía con su
marido quien estaba acusado de
corrupción y prevaricación a esto
también se le añade un enfrentamiento
abierto que Costa mantuvo con el
presidente de la república Marcelo
revelo de Sousa y por si no fuera
suficiente hace poco nos encontramos con
la sorprendente noticia que comentábamos
al principio del vídeo Antonio Costa
Primer Ministro de Portugal dimite al
ser investigado en un caso de corrupción
Así que casi casi que volvemos al
principio del partido Portugal ha
mejorado algunas cosas pero cuando
parecía apostar por un modelo de
atracción de empresas de repente ha dado
un nuevo volantazo en dirección
contraria qué queréis que os diga es lo
que tienen los países latinos que suelen
arreglar arañazos a base de cañonazos en
cualquier caso Esta es la historia de
cómo Portugal logró convertirse en una
de las últimas promesas europeas La
pregunta es logrará seguir siendo l pes
a todo logrará Portugal combatir la
crisis de la vivienda sin arruinar su
economía Qué haríais vosotros para
enfrentaros a este problema como siempre
podéis dejarnos vuestras impresiones en
los comentarios y abrir debate y ahora
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like y suscribiros aiso al politic si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez
más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la
próxima